buckle up welcome to Hannity because we
are less than 12 hours away
Robert Muller's public testimony is
coming yes we'll get some questions
answered about the witch-hunt
expectations the hysteria the breathless
reporting is already begun but look
who's running the show the Cowardly Adam
Schiff Jerry Nadler two of the biggest
liars in Congress hyping tomorrow's
hearing as a major turning point in
their fraudulent two-and-a-half year
witch-hunt against the president four
separate conclusions four separate
investigations they have lied again and
again they have presented what is
nothing short of a hoax multiple
conspiracy theories made false promises
always claiming the president is guilty
of something they can't say but
something conspiracy collusion Russia
Russia Russia defrauding our elections
obstruction of justice some other
phantom crimes their hopes and prayers
have always come up empty I expect the
same tomorrow shouldn't be much
different but let me be honest the
Muller keeps to his word he's going to
stick to the report as the report says
as the report says that's what the
Democrats are asking and that very
report was clear no conspiracy no
collusion no grounds for obstruction and
remember according to Muller legal
precedent on whether or not a sitting
president can or cannot be charged
because a DOJ policy or constitutional
considerations was not a factor in the
special counsels conclusions but
tomorrow the Democratic playbook is
clear it's obvious it's transparent they
want Robert Mullah to contradict his own
findings and implicate smear the
president give them that one soundbite
that they they and their friends and the
media mob will play over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again so they can have another 30
investigations for the next 50 years
meanwhile Republicans my message is to
you tonight and I'm not a registered
Republican I'm a registered conservative
but you're Republicans have a
responsibility tomorrow and frankly a
golden opportunity to perform actual
oversight a broader audience than you
will usually have even fake news CN n
and M s DNC the conspiracy channel their
viewers will be watching too and
you do tomorrow accounts and you are the
ones that must demand accountability
from Robert Muller there are so many
important questions that have never been
asked or addressed and tomorrow that's
your job what happens tomorrow will
impact on a deep level what is the best
constitutional republic God has given
man equal justice under the law equal
application of our laws this will impact
generations to come
because I don't want a some weak
feckless Republicans on Congress to blow
it well we've been following this story
and I'm just gonna try and lay out a
basic fundamental tutorial for these
weak Republicans that have no clue to
follow let me be clear though this is
not me telling people what to do
conservative lawmakers on the Intel and
Judiciary Committee's they don't need my
advice Devin Nunez knows more than I do
so does John Ratcliffe so does Jim
Jordan so does Matt Gaetz so does louie
gohmert
and many well-informed others but sadly
there are well more than a few
Republicans you need to pay attention
and you need to do your job tomorrow and
you better study up and if you need some
help pay close attention because some of
you probably are not well-informed on
this topic which is frankly pathetic and
if you're a Republican that fits into
that category pay attention if you
haven't read the Muller report that
makes you even more pathetic and I'm
sure there are some of you out there now
tomorrow night my goal I don't want to
come on the air here at this time
tomorrow and tell you the viewers the
American people that they blew it that
they had a golden opportunity so to
literally prevent that from happening
I'm going to try and assist for the
American public sake because lies
conspiracy theories and a hoax
have led most of the media coverage but
here's my humble advice if you're
interested always start with the basics
Hannity rule number one no question
should be longer than 10 11 seconds move
fast as the sink direct questions yes or
no questions it's important to get in as
many questions as time permits yes/no
move quickly
Mulla refuses to answer fine move on to
the next question
remind mr. mone you only have five
minutes you
answers to these questions my second
piece of advice start at the beginning
that would be Hillary Clinton listen
closely here are some questions now
again I'm only touching the surface mr.
Muller 18 USC 793 the Espionage Act mr.
Muller you're a career law enforcement
officer if you have classified
top-secret information on a private
server does that violate the Espionage
Act yes or no sir
remind him this is important if we will
have equal justice under the law if he
says that was well I didn't look into
that I don't know move on to the next
question if anyone in America mr. Muller
had email subpoenaed and they decided to
erase and bust up devices with hammers
and destroy the hard drive and remove
SIM cards would that be a slam dunk
obstruction of justice case mr. Muller
if he answers yes or no doesn't matter
keep going if he doesn't move on to the
next set of questions you move on
quickly mr. Muller
when did the counterintelligence
investigation into the Trump campaign
begin and why mr. Muller what about your
original mandate state the mandate
acting AG rod Rosenstein ordered him to
investigate possible coordination
between the Russian government members
of the Trump campaign and any other
matters that rose directly from that
investigation mr. Muller in your view
did your mandate allow you to
investigate fara violations yes or no
taxi medallions yes or no loan
applications yes or no tax fraud yes or
no mr. Muller mr. Muller when did you
first hear about the phony
Clinton bought and paid for Russian
dossier full of Russian lies when did
you first hear about it I don't know
around when tell us when learn when did
you learn that Russian dossier became
the bulk of information used in for FISA
applications to spy on a citizen and the
Trump campaign when did you learn around
when did you learn mr. Muller has a
career law enforcement officer doesn't
the information and a FISA warrant need
to be verified as true before presented
to a judge mr. Muller
give him some history the hill recently
reported the FBI at a spreadsheet on
detailing the dossiers claims they found
over 90% of the dossier was full of
lives mr. Muller State Department
Cathleen kavlock warned the FBI and DOJ
about the dossiers bogus claims they
used it anyway what do you say mr.
Muller
the DOJ official Bruce or he Ray's dog
August and 2016 questions about steals
credibility Hillary paid for the dossier
and that it was never verified but they
used it anyway in the FISA warrants does
the FBI have an obligation to
immediately when they find out that it's
not true what they put in those
applications do they need to go back to
the FISA Court with that information yes
or no if Russia collusion was your
mandate how was it possible you didn't
investigate campaign op research bought
and paid for by Hillary Clinton filled
with Russian lies how is that possible
mr. Muller why not at least refer to
another office for further investigation
like you did with Cohn and taxi
medallions at any point mr. mowett did
you think to investigate if there was a
premeditated fraud committed on the FISA
Court to spy on the Trump campaign mr.
Muller and your final report the dossier
was hardly even mentioned that is a lion
bought and paid for Russian dossier paid
for by a Hillary Clinton why did you not
investigate that you had time to
investigate loan applications taxi
medallions and taxes why did you not
think that was important when that goes
to the heart of your mandate did you
know that the FBI paid Christopher
Steele did you know an oligarch paid
Christopher Steele did you know Hillary
paid Christopher steel did you know the
FBI paid him Christopher steel have you
ever spoken to Christopher Steele if so
how many times What did he say about his
dossier full of Russian lies designed to
hurt Trump and help Hillary in the
election by the way did Bruce or try to
act as a conduit after Steele was fired
for lying and leaking in other words
there are notes that Bruce Orr has do we
you aware that Christopher Steele was
trying to get answers and send you
information while you were Special
Counsel and do you know that Christopher
Steele in an interrogatory and the
threat of perjury I have no idea if any
of this dossier is true did you know he
said that when did you know he said that
you don't know exactly when
when did you know he said that does that
not shock your conscience now you chose
not to make any of issue of this in your
report
why mr. Muller and you had such a broad
mandate to investigate an election
interference why didn't you look into
evidence that Clinton sought ukraine's
help and the DNC was working to get
Ukraine's help to get dirt on Trump to
help Hillary in the 2016 election
why didn't you investigate that does it
matter if the if the influence is coming
from Russia or Ukraine does that matter
next it's important you've got a cover
molar staffing decision this the baller
simple question is it true you chose
Andrew Weissman personally what the New
York Times called your pit bull mr.
Bhalla did you ever read license to lie
by Sidney Powell that talks about
Weissman's god-awful horrific track
record of withholding exculpatory
evidence were you aware of that when
were you aware of that were you aware
that Weissman was a devout Democrat who
was at Hillary Clinton's victory party
by the way who did the vetting and
hiring and the rest of your staff when
did you become aware that your team was
only made up a big-time Democratic
donors and zero Republicans well you
aware that Jeanie ray who worked for you
well she worked for Hillary Clinton on
the Clinton Foundation as her lawyer why
was she on your team do you not see a
conflict of interest why did you fire or
did you fire struck in Paige because we
know Andrew McCabe says he's did did it
it's been reported you didn't save
struck in pages cellphones after you
became aware that they had an anti-trump
bias why why did you send those phones
back - it's it's you know whatever the
factory that they're made in to get
cleaned isn't that basic law enforcement
101 saved the records do you regret only
hiring Democrats at the very least do
you realize the appearance of political
bias and impropriety in your
investigation mr. Buller at what point
in your investigation did you realize
there was no collusion or conspiracy why
did the investigation continue after you
learn the fundamental truth of what you
were investigating now by the way the
issue of obstruction that must be taken
head-on mr. Muller were you having a
tough time on the issue of obstruction
or did you tell not tell the AG rod
Rosenstein and others DOJ policy
constitutional considerations were not a
part of your thinking when it came to a
decision not to charge the president
with a crime
did the president exert any executive
privilege during your investigation
answer's no did he allow your
investigation of full access your team
full access to the White House in terms
of their campaign staff even the White
House Counsel which i think is insane
does the president have the authority
under article 2 to fire an FBI director
or even you did he not have the
constitutional authority to fire you mr.
Muller if he decided to do so tell us
about the interview with President Trump
the day before you were hired as Special
Counsel is that true in that meeting you
spoke to the president did he tell you
you weren't getting the job did he give
you a reason why he fired James Comey
yes or no mr. Muller
why did you not recuse yourself under
those circumstances well considering
you're denied a job by Trump the day
before is it fair to say mr. Malla that
you're friends with Jim Comey were you
angry at his firing mr. Muller
we know that Comey leaked government
materials to get you appointed is that a
potential violation of law could that be
a violation of the Espionage Act sir are
you proud of the way you and your team
treated George papadopolis and had
foreign spies looking into him and that
exculpatory things that he said
apparently were withheld do you wear
that what about your treatment and your
team's treatment of Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn well general Flynn served
this country he was a combat veteran 33
years apparently has been cooperating
with your office for a period of time is
that correct sir he pled guilty to lying
but the FBI agents interviewing
interview him he didn't think they
didn't think he lied right but he made a
plea agreement anyway isn't it true that
he likely made that plea agreement
because he was going bankrupt he had to
sell his house he could no longer afford
legal counsel is it true the reports
that this 33 year old veteran and his
family his son who
and business with him was threatened by
law enforcement mr. Muller are you aware
of that you aware that your team did
didn't take the plea to lie to the FBI
that he had to even though the FBI
agents interviewing him didn't think he
lied do you think he did it maybe to
save his family do you find that type of
prosecutorial tactic fair sir you're I'm
sure proud are you proud of the fact
that we treat a 33 year veteran of this
country who risked his life for this
country this way we know that your buddy
James Comey bragged in an interview that
he took advantage of the chaos and the
Trump administration on day four when he
sent his agents in to interview Flynn
something he said he wouldn't do to
Obama's team or Bush's team does that
bother you about your friend yes or no
mr. Muller now Comey did this after his
deputy FBI director McCabe well he told
Flynn he doesn't need a lawyer when
those lawyers were going in do you
believe in Miranda rights do you think
it's a right way to treat a 33-year
veteran in this country sir would you
treat a veteran like that let's look at
some of the questions posed by our own
Gregg Jarrett they drill down even
deeper on the deep state mr. Muller did
you investigate Christopher Steel Fusion
GPS Glenn Simpson how they supply it
Russian information to the media the FBI
and the DOJ to influence the election
did you investigate whether John Brennan
and James clapper spread the Russian
information about Trump to conspiracy
theorists like Michael Isikoff David
corn in the Washington Post isn't it
true mr. Muller your investigative team
interviewed Christopher Steele at least
once likely twice or three times what
did he tell you did you interview
confidential informants stephane helper
what did he tell you isn't it true that
Halper provided the FBI with exculpatory
information that Carter page George
papadopolis did not conspire with the
Russians why was that not adhered to is
it true that Bruce or shared dossier
information with your pit bull Andrew
Weissman and mr. Ahmad in early of
August 2016 shouldn't they have recused
themselves since they were early
witnesses to the dossiers contents and
they were told that was not verified why
did you select Aaron's lb who
represented Oh Justin
you know the guy that helps set up and
administer Clinton's email system didn't
he smash Clinton's blackberry devices or
is that he accused of that now the final
FISA application and the third renewal
to surveil Carter page and also spy on
then President Trump oh that was done in
June of 2017 you were the special
counsel mr. Muller were you either aware
of this renewal were you involved in
this renewal was any of the information
presented to the FISA Court verified was
the Clinton dirty Russian dossier still
the bulk of information in that fourth
FISA application were you aware that
much of the application was based on
Steele's unverified dossier and when
were you aware of it you ever discussed
with rod Rosenstein the prospects of his
refusal from the case wasn't rod a
witness in the same case that he was
supervising
why didn't you demand his refusal did
the Special Counsel team ever
interviewed Rosenstein as a witness what
did he tell you about the president's
reasons for firing Comey or his
suggestions that the president fired
call me when you met with President
Trump on May 16 2017 why didn't tell why
didn't you tell him you were considering
the next day it turns out taking the
position of special counsel to
investigate him why did you were your
rapport edit and misrepresent a
telephone message left by trumpeter need
out with Michael Flynn's lawyer Robert
Kellner isn't it true that the old the
Office of Legal Counsel opinion did not
prevent you from rendering a conclusion
on whether the evidence did or did not
support obstruction of justice as you
can see we can go on and on and on keep
it tight keep it short he doesn't answer
move on if he starts rambling mr. Muller
I only have five minutes I don't have
enough time yes or no sir ask as many
short questions as possible your mission
should be to inform the American people
about a dirty dossier used to literally
spy on the opposition party candidate
filled with Russian lies that Robert
Muller ignored let the American people
know the true
also breaking news on the eve of this
Muller testimony he actually made a
last-minute request that one of his top
deputies a man by the name of Aaron zeb
li accompanied him during the hearing
wow this is pretty interesting because
this guy served as mullahs chief of
staff at the FBI he also previously
represented Justin Cooper well that's
the former Clinton adviser who was a key
witness in Hillary's email scandal he
helped set up the secret server can't
make this up moments ago the president
tweeted just got back only to hear a
last-minute change allowing a never
Trumper attorney to help out Robert
Muller with his testimony before
Congress tomorrow what a disgrace to our
system never heard of this before very
unfair should not be allowed now we have
to rig witch-hunt and a rigged testimony
of Muller
I guess he's there as a little blankie
security case mother's practice sessions
were not going well because apparently
he's been practicing all week as so has
Nadler moas request that one of his top
deputies president tomorrow's hearings
not the only major development over the
past 24 hours yesterday a letter from
the Department of Justice instructed
Muller that his testimony must remain
within the boundaries of the public
report predictably the media went nuts
saying see Bart doesn't want the truth
choosing the attorney general trying to
silence Robert Muller or intimidate him
ahead of his testimony for almost an
entire news cycle they were totally
feigning their fake phony outrage as
usual
take a look they're still scared he may
go broke there's still a little bit
scared for that 1% possibility
everything we know about Bob Muller he's
a rule follower I think it's incredibly
arrogant of the department to try to
instruct him as to what to say it's part
of the ongoing cover-up by the
administration to keep information away
from the American people you don't need
to tell him to stick to the four corners
of his reports like telling a plant not
to move he didn't need this cutter okay
really
well that didn't happen there was only
one problem they didn't have all the
facts it was Robert Muller himself who
requested the letter ouch the media mob
and Democrats rush to judgment again